mariah camina junto a los vestigios de
la iglesia centenaria y sacra que ordenó
constituir el zar nicolás segundo como
penitencia para salvar la vida de su
hijo enfermo la iglesia ha sido testigo
de los horrores de la segunda guerra
mundial y de los enfrentamientos de 1992
que separó la región de transnistria
moldavia ahora los recuerdos del
conflicto separatista vuelven a estar
presentes en varias estamos en medio de
una zona de conflicto cuando tapó frente
a todo era una niña cuando estalló la
guerra y como nos bombardeaban desde el
otro lado la iglesia se usó como
depósito de armas mandarías no sé el por
qué pero en las últimas semanas ha
habido movimiento de tropas y tanques
hacia chisinau
la aldea provea está en el margen este
del río en este aunque pertenece
administrativamente a moldavia está
enclavada en la región separatista
prorrusa por lo que sus pobladores
comparten la lengua y una buena parte de
la historia aliosha lleva toda su vida
viviendo aquí como la mayoría de los
aldeanos proviene de familias que a los
rusos hablan ruso de los canales de
televisión rusa y compra las siguientes
y pesticidas para su huerto en el
mercado está un clon ya quiere
desestabilizar los
los soldados ucranianos son los que
están atacando transnistria que es
carlos lara
tote
rusia quiere protegernos para cruzar a
otras poblaciones
hay que conducir por puentes sobre el
río ni esther con controles militares de
las fuerzas de interposición rusas como
resultado del alto el fuego de 1992 que
mantiene el conflicto congelado ahora si
la guerra de ucrania cruza las fronteras
desencadenaría en un nuevo foco de
tensión
la presa de ustea fue construida en
tiempos de la unión soviética al igual
que la central hidroeléctrica aunque
está operada por las autoridades de
transnistria también beneficia al pueblo
de guztia pero se comenzó el conflicto
de ucrania se siente las tensiones su
alcalde maxim verdes nos cuenta que
están preocupados desde hace unos meses
en el pueblo de gust ya hay cortes de
suministro de electricidad nos dijeron
que se había roto una turbina hace unos
meses y no han hecho nada creo que es
una forma de presión para que en
moldavia no se vaya a la unión europea
el invierno está cerca y hay una crisis
energética global donde vamos a
conseguir ahora los suministros de gas y
electricidad la singularidad de este
territorio para el que transcurre el
cauce del río ni esther hace que algunas
aldeas como homologada estén divididas
en las dos orillas este viejo ferry de
fabricación rusa solía cargar vehículos
de mercancías para cruzar al otro margen
del río pero ahora debido a las nuevas
restricciones de entrada moldavos a
transnistria no es fácil cruzar los
pasos terrestres rasea toma el ferry
para ir a trabajar aunque le suponga
llegar más tarde antes no era así cruzar
por el puente te llevaba 5 minutos hay
colas enormes porque te piden muchas
cosas trabajo como auxiliar de
enfermería en el ambulatorio y tengo que
cruzar todos los días a veces el ferry
está parado durante horas porque hay
viento
el centro de salud en el que trabaja
raisa es el único para todo molo bata y
las otras dos aldeas moldavas en la
orilla oriental de transnistria rice atm
que si hay una escalada estas
poblaciones quedarían aisladas no sé qué
va a pasar no puedo dejar de pensar en
lo que pasó en 1992 fueron meses
terribles había muchas personas mayores
y niños
fuimos evacuados en botes a otros
pueblos de moldavia y nos tocó vivir
como refugiados
mo lobata depende de los suministros
energéticos y del comercio de
transnistria los ataques ocurridos en
abril en tiráspol capital de
transnistria a menos de 70 kilómetros de
la entrada del pueblo ha puesto a las
autoridades locales en alerta son
momentos de tensión tenemos problemas
con los pasos fronterizos las
autoridades transnistria los cierran
cuando quieren y a veces no dejan entrar
productos agrícolas a moldavia todo el
gas lo traemos de transnistria y tenemos
un contrato de compra-venta hasta
octubre después ya nadie sabe pese a la
separación político territorial
transnistria mantiene acuerdos como el
de aviá en materia de libre circulación
de personas educación y transportes en
los días calurosos de verano familias
transnistria suelen venir a este resort
para disfrutar de la campiña del río ni
esther y reservar paseos en bote catania
conoció a su marido moldavo en chisinau
y sus hijos tienen la doble nacionalidad
los viven en tierras por lo que la
situación no está bien tenemos miedo ha
habido avisos de bomba en los colegios
de transnistria y ahora mis trabajos
están estudiando online y no saben
cuándo volverán a clase somos una
familia mixta con pasaporte ruso y
moldavo sería muy difícil para nosotros
elegir bando
expectantes al futuro moldava de
transnistria os temen que la inseguridad
se instaure y las aguas que escurren
para el cauce del río ni esther vuelvan
a arrastrar el sufrimiento y la
destrucción por la reanudación del
conflicto